[Music]
i'm gonna miss you as well
shit's creek's sixth and final season
leads the television nominations with a
whopping 21 noms
including nominations for the entire
lead cast this series is also recognized
in the best comedy series category
alongside barone's fun sketch show
letter kenny kim's convenience
and working moms you would drink more
wine yes pull your pants up when you're
done
in the drama tv category cardinal until
the night scored
15 nominations including best drama
series other nominated dramas include
burden of truth vikings transplant and
departure
starring the late christopher plummer
the last time the plane was seen
was on departure also with 15
nominations is the critically acclaimed
series trickster
which includes seven nominations for its
cast question who was the first ever
queen to walk in the drag race
the debut season of canada's drag race
received seven nominations
including best reality or competition
series other nominated shows are battle
of the blades
dragon's den the great canadian baking
show and wall of chefs
andrew and jonathan scott's series
property brothers forever home
is the most nominated lifestyle series
with three nominations
everyone's a forever home they want a
home that they can love for the rest of
their lives
now moving over to film horror flick
blood quantum leads
scaring up ten nominations they're
immune
i'm not crime noir achilles escape gets
eight nominations
and the coming-of-age film funnyboy
received nine nominations
including best motion picture is it
wrong for a boy to do it
why the 2021 canadian screen awards main
event will live stream on thursday may
20th